this is the blanding's turtle  look closely because they're hard to  spot in the wild  blanding's turtles aren't very big  topping out at around 10 inches in  length  what distinguishes them is their bright  yellow chin and throat  like the stereotype blanding's turtles  take their time  however once they've reached full  adulthood there's no slowing down  a recent study found an 83 year old  female that was full of eggs ready to  lay  their general habitat is wetlands with  shallow water  their range is centered around the great  lakes extending east to new york and up  to southern ontario  but the wetlands they call home are  shrinking and becoming fragmented from  human development the biggest threat to  the survival of this gentle and timid  creature  this is the blanding's turtle  you